when Kylie Jenner and Travis thought be
pregnant with baby number two the 21
year old reality star teased Instagram
followers late Saturday night with this
super cute pic of the couple getting
cuddly on a staircase and the caption
baby number two question marks of course
fans immediately began speculating that
Kylie and Travis's one-year-old
daughters stormy is getting a brother or
sister and the post got a whopping 7.4
million likes in just over 12 hours but
Kylie squashed those rumors as quickly
as they began when one fan asked
point-blank if she's pregnant and she
responded no lol this isn't the first
time Kai's recently sparked baby rumors
she got the rumor mill pumped last month
when she tweeted I have something really
exciting I could just share soon with
you guys
I've been cooking this up for a while I
can't wait to share my new project
already but she shut down those
pregnancy questions with the same no lol
response while the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star may not be pregnant yet
we do know she and Travis have babies on
the brain hey guys so I am gonna show
you how I get ready on tour in December
a source told et they're going to wait
until Travis finishes his astro world
tour before trying for another baby
adding quote they want to have another
child soon so it's close in age to
stormy but they do not want to do this
while he's busy on the road Friday
actually marked Stormy's first birthday
and while much of the Kardashian family
was posting touching tributes to the
little tot Kylie's big sister Kourtney
was catching heat from one fan for
posting this sultry lingerie snap I
can't even live my life I can't even go
anywhere the follower commented quote
the most touching birthday wish for
stormy to which court clapped back she
doesn't even have Instagram yet but
stormy if you're reading this happy
first birthday
feel like on social media lately
everyone takes themselves so seriously
and I'm over it of course the mom of
three also wished Ernie's a happy
birthday with this sweet photo and the
message my little storm aloo how I love
you so angel girl happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]